sur une note un peu plus légère on
termine ce bilan en faisant quelques
suggestions à nos politiciens pour le
temps des fêtes les gens en profitent
généralement de cette période pour
échanger les cadeaux renouer avec les
amis prendre des résolutions pour la
nouvelle année les politiciens
évidemment ne font pas exceptions c'est
toujours le segment dont j'entends le
plus parler
Michel va commencer avec vous qu'est-ce
qu'on met dans le bas de Noël d'un
policier cette année
dans le bas de Noël du ministre de
l'Éducation Bernard Drainville je mets
un manuel de mathématiques parce que la
vérifiatrice Générale vient de dire
écoutez il y a pas de réduction de
compte au ministère d'éducation ça a pas
de bon sens c'est pas comment si les
programmes fonctionnent comment on a
réussi à faire telle chose ou telle
chose évidemment la réduction de compte
ça commence par des mathématiques alors
il doit traîner vieux manuel de maths
quelque part dans un école on va mettre
ça dans le bot de Noël de Monsieur
drinville ça lui fera des lectures pour
les vacances de lecture légère dans le
temps des fêtes pourquoi pas avec votre
votre cadeau vous dans le bas de Noël je
souhaite agresser un Dubé d'ouvrir son
bon Noël et d'y trouver tout ça toutes
sortes d'infirmiers d'infirmières
écoutez partout au Christian Dubé regard
dans son ministère que ce soit au bloc
opératoire dans les urgences les
infirmières pratiquent spécialisées pour
ces nouvelles cliniques le 81 pour le
triage il manque d'infirmières et
d'infirmiers c'est la colonne vertébrale
du réseau et en manque partout et sans
elle mais il y a plus c'est plus de
femmes majoritairement de redresser le
réseau est-ce qu'il faut les payer
davantage est-ce qu'il faut donc prendre
l'argent d'Ottawa bonifier leurs
conditions est-ce qu'il faut changer la
façon dont on gère les horaires on
essaie toutes sortes de manière du côté
de Christian Dubé pour qui est davantage
d'infirmière avec celles qui sont là ne
s'épuisent pas trop et reste mais ça
reste le casse-tête principal de tout ce
qu'on parle en santé là c'est les
infirmières parce que même avec une
enveloppe d'argent extraordinaire de ta
voix si on n'a pas le personnel ça
fonctionnera pas Chantal votre cadeau à
qui quoi et pas un politicien mais un
compatriote franco-ontarien qui
s'appelle Paulo
de la Commission sur la loi des mesures
d'urgence j'avoue que si j'allais porter
des cadeaux chez lui ce serait bien une
caisse de Red Bull ou bien un abonnement
de café parce que s'il doit produire un
rapport dans les deux langues
officielles latin pour l'ami février il
passera pas un Noël à faire une cure de
sommeil encore pas un gros réveillon non
effectivement je reste avec vous tiens
qui devrait une résolution pour le
nouvel an qui quoi non ouais c'est pour
le réveillon et c'est un
conseil Justin Trudeau et assez ministre
peut-être en 2023 abandonné de manger
mou pour commencer à parler au Canadiens
comme s'ils étaient les adultes qui sont
ça le ferait pas de temps puis en plus
il trouverait peut-être ça bon
Alec en plus vous savez que François
Legault et amis avec dogford en Ontario
et ce texte se parle régulièrement après
une bière ensemble alors la résolution
que je souhaite pour François Legault
c'est de devenir ami avec un autre
Premier ministre une autre province et
je pense qu'il devrait se rapprocher
d'Angry internat avait labrador parce
que l'entente d'approvisionnement
énergétique de Churchill Store se
termine en 2041 ça peut avoir l'air loin
20 ans mais dans la planification
énergétique d'une province 20 ans c'est
très rapide il faut d'abord régler ce
contentieux là sur Churchill Fall pour
être capable d'ouvrir un autre projet
qui serait très portable pour le Québec
celui de girl Island au Labrador où l'on
pourrait installer l'équivalent de trois
fois la puissance de la Romaine les 3
centrales de la romaine au Québec il y a
ça en double à Island jamais Turner ne
peut faire ce projet-là tout seul non
pas les moyens financiers pour le faire
auraient besoin du Québec pour inclure
l'électricité pour le financer mais pour
ça il faut qu'il s'entende sur avant
alors on change le numéro de téléphone
et on texte on va faire un petit tour
Internet et Labrador puis on commence à
placer tranquillement
éventuellement en 2023 mais des bons
rapports pour être capable de régler ça
non mais le Québec en a besoin on peut
pas parler de sobriété énergétique
depuis diminuer le chauffage dans le
jour là mais la vraie solution c'est
Church Falls et Gold Island et ça faudra
recommencer y penser un nouvel ami
Michel dans le bas de la résolution
votre question de départ cette
résolution au choix moi j'ai fait un
choix
un break dans les virus
très bien ouais
un peu plus on est je disais au bord de
l'implosion là dedans et on voit ce qui
est en train d'arriver c'est comme une
triple couronne de virus la grippe
saisonnière était frayante les virus
pour les enfants c'est respiratoire pour
les enfants puis pas fini cette pandémie
là regardez ce qui arrive en Chine
actuellement si la Chine reprend un la
pandémie de micro-ondes ça peut revenir
ça ici on a vraiment besoin d'un break
on se le souhait tous Michel
effectivement voilà
un peu plus difficile c'est comme ça
quand même qu'on va conclure notre
émission aujourd'hui notre dernière
émission 2022 merci encore de nous avoir
accompagné au cours des derniers mois on
va faire alors pendant quelques semaines
on va vous retrouver le 15 janvier merci
à tous nos collègues d'un bout à l'autre
du pays qui nous donne fier à coup de
pouce chaque semaine merci à vous trois
d'avoir été là merci d'être encore là en
2023 c'est un plaisir de vous avoir
autour de la table et merci à vous
d'être là chaque semaine à la maison
c'est Daniel Thibault à Montréal au nom
de toute l'équipe je vous souhaite une
excellente fin de journée une bonne
période des fêtes et je vous retrouve le
15 juin
[Musique]